hello everyone um you may remember
a few years ago 2016 in the fall to be
precise that
i recorded a video alerting people to
what i saw as the dangers of
a bill c-16 that i regarded as an
attempt to make compelled speech
mandatory in canada
many of you
watching this will
be
familiar with the events that transpired
in consequence unfortunately i feel
compelled to do something similar today
in a variety of different ways in
relationship to another bill a
provincial one this time bill 67
which purports to
address racial racist issues in the
entire ontario education system i'm
going to read something that i wrote
about this
as a warning
a warning to citizens of ontario and
canada bill 67 which purports to be
nothing but an anti-racist bill
is in fact the most pernicious and
dangerous piece of legislation that any
canadian government has attempted
to put forward and i hope i'm not saying
that lightly
it will make the man it will make
mandatory the subversion of the entire
education system in ontario k12 as well
as colleges and universities to the
radically leftist doctrines known as
critical theory
a thoroughly anti-western ideology both
postmodern and marxist in its derivation
based on the idea that all our extant
institutions are racist sexist and
discriminatory
in their essence critical theorists
assume that history is best understood
as the war between identity groups with
one group always oppressing and all
other groups always victimized and
exploited
critical theorists dismissed the idea of
the sovereign free individual claiming
that belief in such sovereignty and
freedom does nothing but justify the
oppression and exploitation of the
marginalized
in keeping with that rejection such
theorists assume that human identity
itself is best understood at the group
level with markers of race sex so-called
gender and sexual preference dominating
critical theorists reject the
presumption of individual innocence
absent proof of wrongdoing
assuming that membership in a group
regarded as dominant and exploitative is
sufficient to indicate the moral
culpability of any given member of that
group
critical theorists define offense and
harm
as subjectively determined anyone who
feels victimized by any statement made
by anyone for any reason is fully
justified in their feeling and cl of
and claim of harm regardless of the
intent
of the author of the statement who is
then to be deemed guilty of such
victimization and denied even the
opportunity for a reasonable defense
bill 67
will mandate the creation of
institutions of inquisition in every
educational institution
to which anyone who has an opinion or
undertakes an action that is perceived
to violate the tenets of critical theory
will be made
necessarily subject to punishment
the author of this bill
mpp laura mae lindo ndp kitchener center
is former head of equity
at laurier university it was laura mae
lindo who developed the policies that
resulted in the circumstances that
enveloped lindsay shepard in 2017
which produced a scandal provincially
nationally and internationally left a
permanent stain on canadian universities
on the reputation of canadian
universities and demolished that young
woman's academic ambitions
and future
the fact that the ontario conservative
government has allowed and even
encouraged such legislation to be put
forward under their aegis and then
ignorant and careless enough to vote in
support of it
is a woeful indication of both the
perniciousness and deviance of the ideas
that the legislation contains
and evidence of their own the
conservatives own stunning and continued
inability to see the dangers such
doctrines present
it is much harder to actually deal
with the fact of the sometimes unjust
distribution of privileges and resources
in a complex society than to kowtow
to radicals who know how to viciously
excu accuse
weaponized guilt and claim through
manipulative sloganeering the moral
upper hand but there's no excuse for the
conservatives and for the classical
liberals who also believe in the
sovereignty of the individual
to trumpet their compassion for the
oppressed by allowing authoritarian
ideologues to gain their treacherous way
this bill 67 threatens the integrity of
all the systems that will educate all
the young people in ontario for decades
to come if it passes the rest of the
provinces in canada will follow suit
the fact that this bill is already
through second reading is inexcusable
wake up canadians before you do yourself
and your children
irreparable
harm